you are a theoretical physicist of the
specialization and early universe
cosmology and you and I both studied
together on the different poles of
experiment and theory way backs
beginning in 1993 at Brown University
and oh yeah and I want to take us back
to those two those heady days in the
early part of the or the late part of
the previous Millennium Eye it makes us
sound really old let me talk like that
but I want to talk about how our careers
have kind of been mirror images of one
another you pursuing theoretical
pursuits in cosmology and mine in
experimental but kind of loosely coupled
like Cooper pairs across the the
Brillouin skier or something like that
none other than leon cooper your
colleague our former professor at at
Brown University we were taking his
advanced quantum o'clock mechanics I
don't know if you remember this but yeah
we were in that class I barely could
handle regular quantum mechanics and
here he was and I remember him saying so
I asked a question and he's like well
you obviously didn't pay attention in
your undergraduate quantum mechanics
class and I was half tempted to say well
I learned undergraduate quantum
mechanics from your book but I didn't
say I didn't have can you imagine that I
don't even think Leon what he would have
smacked me upside the head
there's no suit Leon Cooper's right yeah
tell us about him
tell us about him what does he mean what
does he mean to physics there's a you
know almost 50 öre problem called
superconductivity that was actually
right experimentalist in 1911 kamerlingh
onnes yes yeah discovered experimentally
that metals you know will you know
conduct with zero resistance and there
was no explanation fit theoretically
and everybody worked on it including
Einstein Fineman Landau you name it
surely a Heisenberg and a very young guy
named Leon Cooper and the important
thing about Leon was he was an outsider
so he was trained as a particle
physicists you know you know a New
Yorker
like us yeah and body and took him out
to Illinois and
body actually literally wanted you know
somebody that was not a condensed matter
person to work on a problem because he
felt that they would have fresh eyes and
an outsider's perspective and it proved
to be correct and you know the important
thing about Leon is he is
you mean the you know he basically took
that what seventeen hour train ride for
Illinois back to New York and decided to
just he tried all these calculations and
say you know what I'm just gonna like
see the problem as a physics problem and
just like throw away the math and just
like you know just do some dirty physics
use my intuition and he cracked the code
he saw a super common you know he came
up with a key idea which is that
fermions can pair up to act as a quasi
kind of you know basically effectively
act as a spin zero particle that enabled
this collective effect such that that
collective effect of the spin zero
particle could conduct without any
resistance and it led to some
predictions and and earned him a Nobel
Prize and one of the things Leon always
used to tell me whenever I he would make
me feel stupid he said I'm you know
Einstein once told me I was like okay
that if if we knew what we are talking
about we wouldn't call it research yep I
was one of his chestnuts yeah and like
one one one other interesting I think
very powerful Leon Cupra story I think
that really kind of in I is my lantern
all right for how I do things and how I
do everything in might and my work
include my mentoring of students one
time after 15 years I figured out you
know that I was gonna come back and like
impress him you know like I had already
been a young professor I just gotten
tenure I got this fancy you know
ApS award in all this sweater right and
I Drive back and Leon is there he's just
about to retire I go in his office and I
start again a blackboard and I I figured
out I knew all this like all this math
and all the stuff sitting there and by
the time I'd witness
Michael Peskin that was like a pol and
it was like a big thing for us and I
write the scene and he goes you know
Stefan you just slow down I mean you
know I think I'm a pretty smart guy but
you just gotta slow down and I'm like
wow you know it's like he set me up for
the sucker punch him like oh wow Leon is
like you know I'm going too fast to the
master so then he goes and you know why
don't you find a real problem and like
work on it like fine you find yourself a
real problem like a heart problem like a
real physics problem and like dedicate
yourself and work on it and I was like
you know I've you know it was like the
deathblow of this kung-fu movies like
only three days later you start like you
know have an internal bleeding in my
well like I've been wasting 15 years of
my time like you know chasing whatever
yeah
shape chasing you know chasing the
company basically yeah
identify my problem like you know and
actually I thought about you because you
had been to you as it experimentalists I
call you you know a theoretical
experimental have been had been chasing
that right you have been noon for
decades yeah I think I was talking about
this with Janna Levin who you connected
me with on the podcast recently and I
said you know physicists sort of have to
cultivate a brand like what their tastes
are and I think you exemplify that as
well as and I hope we can get into this
as well not just within the research
domain where you're you know eminently
you know successful and your research
program of coming up with a brand the
Alexander brand which as a
characteristic style which is different
you know then someone like Janna who
write and but but on the same token
having you know having a very
disciplined approach to to research but
also being able to communicate ideas to
a lay audience and and I think
exemplified in this book how you really
have an ability which which I you know
as I discuss with her there aren't so
many people like her like you who can
both communicate to to the lay person
but also can can do cutting-edge
research
Oh